that CBS News poll out this morning
shows president Trump's job approval
rating at 40% that's up from 37 percent
in January but a majority of Americans
55 percent still disapprove of the
president's performance and that could
affect elections in North Carolina
Indiana Ohio and West Virginia where
primary contests are being held today ed
O'Keefe is in Charleston West Virginia
with more on that story ed good morning
Gail good morning all those races across
the country but it's what's happening
here in West Virginia that has top
Republicans concerned there's a
candidate named Don Blankenship he
served federal prison time falsely
accused Mitch McConnell of smuggling
cocaine from China and said the
president is misinformed despite all
that he might end up to be the
Republican nominee for US Senate if we
don't stop the increase in the debt
we're gonna bankrupt okay hours before
voters headed to the polls Don
Blankenship said he's the best choice
for West Virginia 29 fighters killed at
a Big Branch mud the former mining
executives spent a year in federal
prison following an explosion at one of
his minds something his opponents
Attorney General Patrick Morrissey and
Congressman Evan Jenkins don't want
voters to forget he was convicted of
conspiracy or intentionally violating
mine safety standards Blankenship
himself hasn't shied away from
discussing the incident you don't bear
any responsibility for the death of
those 29 people that bear the same
responsibility that you would bear if
the government came in and blew your
house up F while you were gone for ten
years survivors of the explosion are
also speaking out hoping that fellow
West Virginians reject their former boss
actually cried I said man this man just
won't quit
goose Stewart was in the Upper Big
Branch mine the day of the blast I
remember him getting those initial nine
guys outside I remember picking him up
and carrying him I remember don't sleep
ER Oh despite his past Blankenship has
momentum and some survey suggests he
could win he worked hard he clawed
himself
he became successful and I'll say more
power to President Trump even tweeted
his concerns urging West Virginians not
to vote for Blankenship the candidate
told us that the president had been fed
fake news remember the president won
this state by more than 40 points in
2016 that's why Republicans think
they've got a good shot at defeating
Democrat Joe Manchin they worry however
Blankenship could spoil those chances
John it's a fascinating race head thank
you so much